for the next in the party tribe we can't
come to Steven so the ability when the
oh she's a envy owned in tar didn't
blaming our monarch infecting the demo
become keygen wooden is kind and drag of
upstream additional problem ltd final
and infancy upsets filigree chef tzorin
guilt invisibility going submit as I'm
the nominee in the entire octave um
acorn out shoes for Khalid in valence
unambitious
China England echidna and intuition
sites actuary be better if not the case
we can see from the country getting
Buddha
wouldn't you know how to fistful field
Spanish student keine and when they're
hoping a massive decline over alpha
upsets six tilt am failing so without
engine immensity of meeting and you
nominal texting for earthly confessed in
the chamber bow that they interact is
impresses of unreal dissipation drop
shafts in salads from FEMA and give me a
minute learning cancer hope happy
conjugating here to Buddha kind and drag
of upstream in Parliament still came
esophagus obsessed by Indian drug of and
yum da ha
as anga nominee declare on this rod the
Commission betreff India gave me see
that their CEO Pete infants forensic
makes to see our paddies of the patent
Aaron Aaron on disease of all in DubLi
Hawaii of Matilda's electrons and
systems from the malachite saucepan
Tannenbaum Melda wouldn't so we'd sofa
vending the blood Carter a pseudonym the
power sunlight will lead our Imam or am
I going to clean our cell I was in Nam
the Commission's presence
it's an expletive nom de Stratos for
ministering to permanent members of the
Parliament thank you for this
opportunity to discuss the outcome of
the
25 with just finished in in Madrid
you are certainly aware that the
conference ended 42 hours after the
scheduled a delay with his
to the difficulties encountered during
the negotiation with your permission I
will come back to these difficulties in
a moment I would like to point out some
important progress that was made in the
EU climate policy last week firstly a
last Wednesday the Commission presented
at the European Green Deal a roadmap to
embed climate action into all policies
secondly one of the main priorities of
the Finnish presidency was reached in
the European Council that after a long
debate endorsed the objective of
achieving a climate neutral EU by 2050
in line with the objectives of the very
agreement however one member state at
this stage was not able to commit to
implementing this objective as far as it
was concerned and the European Council
will come back to this Member States
position in June 2020 the decision by
the European Council is a step forward
the EU has now agreed on the common
objective of climate neutrality and all
Member States but one have committed to
implementing it it is important that the
work continues and that next year all
Member States will commit to its
implementation
now honourable members coming back to
the Madrid conference I would like to
recall what was at stake at the
conference both for the planet and for
the EU cop 25 had three major objectives
first and foremost to finalize the
rulebook on the issue of carbon markets
as laid down in article 6 of the battery
agreement second to complete the review
of the worst of international mechanism
for loss and damage and finally to agree
on the extension and revision of the
gender action plan on these objectives
the EU negotiation position was clear
the rules on article 6 should ensure
robust accounting for the use of
international carbon markets should
avoid double counting and should also
guarantee environmental integrity
concerning the worst of
mechanism rollers and damage the you
should resist calls to create additional
institutional mechanisms but suit
support instead solutions that provide
that that would provide for countries to
effectively address loss and damage
associated with climate change as to the
gender action plan the EU was supportive
of an expansion and revision which
strengthens gender considerations and
women's participation in climate action
on 2nd December addressing the
conference on behalf of the EU the
presidency made it clear that in front
of this climate emergency the one this
Parliament declared last month we had to
change our approach dramatically and
embrace the Green Revolution our
objective being to make Europe the first
climate neutral continent on the planet
by 2050 indeed during these two weeks of
negotiations it became increasingly
clear that there was an elephant in the
room ambition which was not on the
agenda of this cop turn out to be a
major issue a number of parties together
with NGOs the youth with accrediting
body and the public at large in their
thousands in the streets of Madrid
called
on the cop to do more to address the
climate emergency here I salute our team
of negotiators who spent no effort and
worked literally 24/7 to achieve the
best possible results their task was
made extremely difficult because a small
number of parties either refused to
engage or insisted on mechanisms under
under article 6 that could potentially
be the death knell of the Paris
agreement until the very last hours of
the cop the EU showed the maximum
possible flexibility in the view of
striking a deal which would preserve the
environmental integrity
unfortunately it proved impossible
ladies and
there were several lessons to be drawn
from this experience first standing
fights principles for the common good
the EU is increasingly recognized as the
champion and the main actor of the Paris
agreement by loading the EU Green Deal
we translate our words into action
second great progress has been made
although no agreement was reached on
article 6 the quality of the texts on
the table has significantly improved an
agreement on this text of the cop 26 in
classical next year seems Within Reach
and third we read in the news that the
results of the cop are disappointing but
we should look at what has been achieved
the review of the warsaw international
mechanism for loss and damage and of the
framework for capacity building have
been successfully completed and the
chandra action plan has been extended
and it was agreed that the work on the
global climate action agenda would
continue beyond 2020 so ladies and
gentlemen to conclude the EU will
continue to negotiate the implementation
of the Paris agreement in the same
spirit in 2020 parties will have to
update their nationally determined
contributions and submit their long-term
strategy I would take this opportunity
to call on all parties to update their
nationally determined contributions in a
manner that reflects their highest
possible ambition I look forward to this
debate and I thank you very much for
your attention
Finland for ministry to provide in his
premium the Commission the strength of
any Commission's president a moment
honourable members the European Union
and its member states as shown by the
member states present the delegation of
the European Parliament and the
Commission stand firm behind the Paris
agreement we stand firm behind the
global transit
to climate neutral future and the
Commission believes in a green deal for
Europe to lead the way the Copa Madrid
is now behind us it did not lead ever
what we traveled therefore on
international carbon markets and on
other issues for Europe there were some
bridges that we just could not cross if
we want to lead on climate if he wanted
to stay credible towards our
international partners if we wanted to
respond to the young people in the
streets and to citizens here at home in
Europe who are asking for action and a
plan for the climate to put it plainly
we could not support global rules that
would undermine the very integrity of
global climate action we could not
endorse an outcome that would take us
back on climate instead of taking us and
the rest of the world forward but now we
in Europe we will be looking forward we
will build on the global consensus to
work next year to increase climate
ambitions worldwide I noticed and I
think many of us who were there I
noticed that the world is watching us
and they know that our task is more
urgent than ever
last week we presented in your
Parliament the European Green Deal which
is our proposed roadmap to take climate
action across all our policies we
committed to climate neutrality by 2050
and we set out a timeline to increase
our ambition for our missions reductions
in 2013 that's Europe's momentum to
increase ambitions worldwide and we will
work with lent listt next year to do
this and I have to say quite a number of
countries in Madrid who were interested
by this and who want to talk to us to
see whether we can create alliances and
help them do the same by cop 26 in
Glasgow
we intend to propose to update our
nationally determined contributions to
tackle climate change we also need to
submit our long-term strategies in line
with the Paris objectives and in the
European Union we are ready
this we cannot afford to leave anyone
behind at the Copa Madrid Europe showed
solidarity with the countries that are
most vulnerable to climate change we
must make sure that we help the most
vulnerable in their climate efforts so
that they are taken along in this effort
that they have the capacity to deal with
with the changes so they find courage
and hope in a better sustainable future
you know
nothing makes such an impression as to
talking representatives from countries
that can quite literally disappear if we
don't do anything about climate change
so I think that we have can build the
capacity to deal with the changes so
that we together with them can find the
solutions this is what our citizens want
in Europe they wanted also for people
outside of Europe the EU and its member
states already provide more than 40% of
the global climate finance Europe will
continue to scale it up in line with the
Paris agreement so we remain firmly
committed to boosting global climate
finance and to support developing
countries we remain committed to
achieving the 100 billion dollar
financial goal and financially financing
the key funds under the Convention and
Paris agreement we look forward to the
commencement of deliberations on the
post 2025 goal at Kop 26 to submitting
information on our finance beyond 2020
next year and to taking further action
to align global finance with the Paris
goals honourable members this commission
and this Parliament know that people are
calling for action and that in fact they
are taking action on the streets
themselves to push us for more ambition
and a concrete climate plan most of us
who have children you know talk to at
home what are you doing are you doing
enough you should be doing more and it's
a good thing it's a good thing to see
this young generation lead us it's a
good thing to see that the 16 year old
climate activist was named Person of the
Year by Time magazine it's good that
this generation is taking this huge
responsibility
I think our Green Deal
responds to the calls the Green Deal is
a start for Europe to reinvent itself to
to base our wealth and our well-being on
not just on carbon to get rid of that as
an essential element I believe it's a
once-in-a-lifetime opportunity to
deliver a greener and cleaner future for
our citizens without leaving anyone
behind next year on the global stage we
will work with our partners to raise
global ambitions
we'll fight to make sure that we all
face head-on the urgent challenges of
climate change I know we can count on
this Parliament to do that and I know
that this Parliament understands that
the fact that Europe is only 9% of
emissions does not give us an excuse to
not do anything because I've also seen
in Madrid that if we lead others will
follow if we need others will be
convinced to do the same way if we need
those who are hesitating today will no
longer be hesitating tomorrow thank you
very much mr. president
feeling thank you mr. Timmons Rickman
actually leaves it what I mean
Finnick a president